can we describe
the principles the fundamentals of one
of the interesting systems you've
developed which is the leglock system
yeah anything in particular or just like
a general
understanding what are some of the major
principles of it well
it's like me coming to uh miyamoto
musashi and asking can you describe
the principles of sword fighting
you're too generous um let's
start off with some context um when i
began the sport of jiu-jitsu i was
taught
a fairly classical approach to
jiu-jitsu which leglocks were a part of
it but not an emphasized part of it
um the overall culture of the times was
the mid-1990s the overall culture of the
time
saw leglocks as
uh
largely ineffective it was we were told
that
against good opposition they just didn't
work very well they were low percentage
techniques
we were also told that they were
tactically unsound
because if you ever attempted them and
you lost control of the leg lock
um uh your opponent would end up on top
of you or in some kind of good position
and you'd be in
terrible trouble um and we're also told
that they were unsafe
that uh if they were applied in the gym
there'd be far too many injuries and
people would be badly hurt
and that was the received wisdom of that
time
and so i didn't even would work with
them at all
and they would be shown occasionally in
the gym
and you'd learn them you drilled them um
and uh but inspiring i showed no
interest
um you probably know that change when i
met
the the great american grandpa dean
lester who
uh early in his career was using
achilles logs with
considerable success i met him in the
gym wonderful fella
and um to kill these locks is like a
straightforward yes that's correct yes
and um uh he went on to become a
heel hooker and win 280 cc's later on in
his career but we never met again after
after that
and uh that
opened some doors of inquiry and
uh well he asked this first principles
question is why would you only use half
the
body yes in a game which makes a human
body perfect sense
so that opened doors to to inquiry and
if you looked around the judicial world
at that time um
the number of specialized leg lockers
was
very small and most of them were from
outside of conventional uh jiu jitsu
for example you could look around and
see people like romina sato had
sharp leg locks for that time period in
the 1990s um
so they were out there they existed and
you'd see people like ken shamrock would
would use uh hill hawks in in
competition and he had some
some good success with them
when i began experimenting with the in
the gym
uh fairly soon certain truths
started to become evident and
uh the most important of these can be
understood very quickly and they were
relatively easy to discover
the first was that most people
when they went to
understand and study leglocking
and when i talk about leg locking i'm
going to talk about one specific type
which is the most high percentage type
this is leg locks which are performed
with entanglements of your opponent's
legs with your legs there are other
forms of leg lock but these are
relatively low percentage
and don't figure heavily in competition
so i'll i'll ignore them
most people made no distinction between
the mechanism of control
versus the mechanism of breaking
the heel hook is what ultimately
breaks the the angle but the mechanism
of control is the entanglement of your
legs
to your opponent's legs the japanese
term ashigorami literally just means
like
leg entanglement it's a generic term it
could apply to any form of entanglement
there are many options
my idea was let's focus on the
entanglement first
and worry about the breaking mechanism
second
this was analogous to the idea of
position before submission
only you couldn't talk about it in terms
of conventional positions because
ashigorami doesn't really fit into the
traditional hierarchies
positional hierarchies of jiu-jitsu so
the
the the conversation was switched from
position to submission to control
to submission now
wrapping two of your legs around one of
your opponent's legs gives you many
different options you can do it with
your feet on the outside
so-called 50-50 variations you can do
with your feet on the inside
and form what uh
we'll go inside foot position
there's pros and cons to both there's
also methods of
harmonizing the two so you have one foot
on the inside and one foot on the
outside
you can do it with a straight uh
leg where you heel hook from the outside
or you can bring the leg across your
center line and
your hook from the inside you will start
to
notice as you work through these
different variations that
some present advantages over others
all of them come at a price to some
degree
regardless of which ashi gourami option
you use there will be some degree of
foot exposure on my part to my opponent
and some degree of back exposure
on my part relative to my opponent so
that's the downside of it
variations within those different
ashigorami
enable you to lessen danger in some
respects
and at the price of gaining dangers
in others so you get this wider array of
choices
there's not this kind of simplistic
hierarchy that you see in
the basic positions of you too but there
are hierarchies
i do for example generally favor inside
here hooks over outside heel hooks
if i feel my opponent is very good
at exposing my back while i'm in
ashigarami i generally prefer 50 50
situations
if i believe my opponent is very good at
counter leg locks i generally prefer
my feet on the inside working with
variations of
insights and cargo etcetera etcetera so
there are
broad heuristic rules that we can give
to work in these situations
once you start to understand there's a
variety
of entanglements you can use then you
start getting to the really interesting
ideas
that as you perform one given attack
one given here hook you can flow through
different forms of ashigorami where
you can create new dangers and avoid
possible uh uh pitfalls
in a very short time frame as you switch
from one ashigorami to another over time
so that as your opponent's lines of
resistance to an initial attack change
you can accommodate those by switching
to another form of ashigorami
so that your mechanism of control is
always pointing in opposite directions
of his escape
and if you focus on this idea of
control through the legs you can
completely change
the nature of leg locking and take it
away from what it was in the 1990s an
opportunistic
method of attack based upon surprise
speed and power
into one based on control if you can do
this
you can undermine
many of the basic criticisms of leg
locking which were prevalent when i
began
the sport of jujitsu for example
if i can completely control and
immobilize you
i can perform the lock very very safely
if my only way of breaking your leg is
to be faster and more powerful than you
nine times out of term when i apply it
i'm going to hurt your leg
as much by accident as anything but if i
can completely immobilize you
and as every attempt you make to escape
i can follow you
and immobilize you in new directions
then
i can apply the the lock with as much
force or as little force
as possible and so you'll see in our
training room despite over
considerably more than um two decades
sorry a decade and a half now of of
uh hillocking using these methods
the number of people severely injured by
hill hawks is
is tiny like um
i would say i've seen more people
injured by far by
kimuras in the time i've been training
than i have by heel hooks
despite them having a similar twisting
uh
dynamic to them if you build a culture
where people focus on control rather
than speed of execution
then the injury rate goes down
appreciably
the whole idea of positional loss
everyone was critically critical of leg
loss now if you go for leg ox and they
don't work
well now you're in trouble the guy's
going to be on top of you they never
make that criticism with arm bars
okay you can be in the mounted position
go for a number end up on bottom lose
the armbar and lose position but
i've never heard anyone criticize
armbars on that account
more importantly i believed
from early on that the best place to
attack leg locks is not top position
it's bottom position you'll see that
over 90 of my
athletes attack leg locks from
underneath people not on top of people
so there is no position or loss you're
already underneath them
and so that criticism was null and void
um and by focusing on this idea of
breaking down and distinguishing between
the mechanism of control and the
mechanism of breaking
that created something new and something
interesting
there was also another advantage that
i had in terms of creating influence
with leg locking
when you look at the great leg lockers
of the past they they were basically
iconoclasts they were people who
came out of nowhere who just had
this remarkable success with leglocks
[Music]
but
they were just seen as unique
individuals they had their game and they
were good at it
what was unique about the squad is you
had not just one person but a team of
people
who came out and did pretty much the
same thing
these people had very different body
types and very different personalities
so it wasn't that one kind of body type
was good at it you had tall people like
gordon ryan you had uh short people like
nikki ryan
you had someone in the middle like gary
tonin
you had fast people like gary tony had
slow people like gordon
um there were
there was every kind of body type
involved and it was like people could
see this was different because it
it worked for an entire team as opposed
to a unique individual who had unique
attributes
and then started to foster the belief
that
if it can work for a team it can work
for anyone
which means it can work for me and i
think that had a big effect
that's why i owe a lot to
those early students
[Music]
gordon ryan gary tony and eddie cummings
and
nikki ryan there it was those four kids
came from nowhere um uh
gary had some success in grappling like
low-level success and grappling before
uh before becoming a full-time member of
the squad
but the others were just nobodies who
no one had known and yet within a
five-year time frame they were all going
up against world championship
competition and doing exceedingly well
and um which gives further credence the
idea of the five-year
program and um uh
i think by operating as a team those
young men did an
incredible job of convincing the
grappling world that this wasn't just
about
well they're just different or they're
it works for their body type or
or them as individuals it was like no if
a team can do it
anyone can do it and i think that's what
really
convinced people that this was something
worth studying this is something that
could be a big part of their lives but
also convince you and convince
convince each other in those early days
when you're developing the science
essentially what was missing is an
entire science and system
of use of leglocks because it's not like
you
knew for sure that there's a lot here to
be discovered in terms of control you
perhaps hadn't just like you said an
initial intuition
but you know you have to have enough um
there's perseverance required to uh take
is the giant eye thing to take from the
initial idea to an entire system
is there is there a sense you have about
how
complicated and how big this world of
control
uh in the in leg locks is
how complicated is it you've achieved a
lot of success you have a lot of
powerful ideas in terms of inside
outside what's high percentage what's
not
what's high reward what's a low risk all
those kinds of things
the and then you also mentioned kind of
transitions
not transitions but how you move with
your opponent
to uh resist their escape through
control
this is how much do you understand about
this world this is a fascinating
question
um as a general rule
the most
the most powerful developments are
always at the onset of a project
okay let's give an example um
the jet engine was uh
i believe first conceived in the late
1930s
just around the time of world war ii it
was developed
with great pace because of world war ii
that obviously military research was a
huge thing back then and first
fielded i believe by the germans uh
in around 1943. um
jet aircraft didn't play a big role in
world war
ii they were there at the end and they
did play a significant role but
in terms of numbers they just weren't
there
so by around 1945 you had the onset
of the jet age and the jet engine began
to replace the piston engine
in most aircraft it was it was the new
way of of doing things
if you look at the pace of development
of jet engine aircraft technology from
1945
to 1960 it is
unbelievable there was a solid
decade where they were gaining almost
100 miles an hour
per year for a decade that's a form of
growth
that i mean in the world of engineering
that's
that's the only time you see growth like
that is on things like bitcoin
and that's about it okay um
uh let's put things in perspective okay
in world war ii the standard us aircraft
bomber
was the b-17 which was a
mid-sized bomber with a fairly limited
load capacity and
i think top speed well below 300 miles
an hour
just 10 years later you had the b-52
which could fly across continents and
deliver nuclear weapons
and carry bomb loads of up to 70 000
pounds
uh in a decade that happened
i if you took a b-17 pilot
in 1943 and put them inside a b-52
a decade later he would literally think
he was on a ufo
a ship from another planet that was the
speed
of development now contrast that
with the speed of modern development if
i took you in a time machine
and i put you in a civil airliner in
1972
let's say a boeing 737 it's not that
different from what you fly in today
that's right flies at the same speed has
the same range
flies at the same altitude it's not that
different
the amount of progress between 1973
and 2020 isn't very impressive
but the amount of progress from 1945
to 1955 or even better 1960 was
staggering
and so the initial progress tends to be
meteoric but after that it tends to be
incremental
that's that with lake longs there's a
guy named elon musk
there's been almost no development in
terms of
uh space
rocket propulsion and rocket
launches and going out into orbit or
going out into deep space
and one guy comes along one john donahue
type character
and says it doesn't make sense why we
don't use reusable rockets
why we don't make it much cheaper why we
don't launch every week as opposed to
every few years
it doesn't make any sense why we don't
go to the moon again over and over and
over it doesn't make any sense why we
don't go to mars and colonize mars
it feels like it's not just a single
jump to a b52 it's a series of these
kinds of jumps
so the question is is there another leap
within the leg locking system time will
tell
um i do believe that
we're in a phase now where the really
big
jumps have already been made and we're
we're in the incremental phase at this
point
um what i do believe is that you will
start to see new directions
start to emerge where you start to see
the interface between leg locking and
wrestling for example
the interface between uh leg locking and
back attacks and that will provide
new avenues of direction which will
provo
uh create new spurs of growth
um but in terms of breaking people's
legs this the simple act of breaking
legs i i believe are in the incremental
phase now rather than the meteoric phase
you